j'ai animé une fois c'est mon pire
souvenir d'animation plus elle est
vraiment c'était en direct c'était à
cannes mais alors c'est un enfer absolue
russe et c'est un bordel le public est
là il hurla pour le coup dur pour le
vrai mais experts annoncer franchement
c'est une bien pour moi c'est de pire
animer ces voix là les artistes sont là
mais franchement ils sont ils sont très
stressés il vous écoute peu ou pas ils
n'ont pas le temps de répéter femmes ont
vraiment c'est compliqué alors il ya eu
aussi alerte enlèvement où sont les
stars c'est plus comme avant mdr ya plus
qu'une star internationale qui dure
depuis longtemps même drc éclaté quand
même alors même si on adore les
téléspectateurs voilà qui adore vita
slimane gims ghanem a aussi gelé qui fin
c'est que des potes et je suis très
content qu'ils sont repartis avec eux
avec plein de prix un détail slimane
sont des chanteurs qu'on retrouve dans
beaucoup d'autres émissions et c'est
vrai qu'il n'ya pas eu cette année le
petit plus des nrj music awards regardez
on vous a fait une évolution de la
cérémonie et dans trois ans je pense que
ce sera ma tante la grosse cote
[Rires]
[Musique]
au départ pas où te papa ou t elle au
quotidien
léon
encore
[Musique]
2021 je pense qu'on aura des verts le
frelon voilà et y en a de plus en plus
tôt qui laisse des magnétos on vous a
fait une petite compil des gens pas là
et c'est vrai qu'il est assez longue
regardez sur trois ne nous mentons bon
sens lantern bonsoir mon compte se
battre n'est pas là ce soir
mariah carey est en duplex avec l'eau
depuis los angeles
meetic
la défense j'aimerais vraiment être avec
vous ce soir pour fêter ça et soeurs
elton john
bonsoir et merci des black eyed peas
salut paris lady gaga et rihanna
[Applaudissements]
il ya un truc qu'il faut qu'il faut
juste comprendre alors si le point
commun tous les années c'est que j'étais
depuis toutes ces années j'ai vu j'ai vu
les cérémonies tout j'étais toute la
cantine avec beyoncé donne à britney
spears une année le truc c'est qu'on est
dans une industrie qui a perdu
énormément d'argent depuis 20 ans donc
faire venir
beyoncé aux nrj awards c'est à coups de
152 sur un euro pour la maison de
disques
sauf que les artistes américains faut
savoir une chose c'est qu'ils ne vendent
pas beaucoup de disques en froissant
universal music qui va faire venir
rihanna ils vont dépenser le jet le
machin à cannes les 25 danseurs ça va
leur coûter 300 mille caprices dix mille
albums derrière il a eu un truc c'est
que c'est que l'industrie est la plus
les mots pour faire venir ses stars là
tout simplement